madame monsieur bonsoir le 30 janvier
1933 il ya donc 60 ans le chef de l'état
allemand
le maréchal hindenburg charge et adolf
hitler de constituer un gouvernement de
coalition
ouvrant ainsi la voie à 12 années de
nazisme qui allait ravager l'europe et
faire plus de 40 millions de victimes
soixante ans après les allemands sont
descendus massivement dans la rue pour
manifester leur opposition à la
renaissance du racisme et de la
xénophobie dans leur pays
reportage de notre correspondant
permanent à berlin pascal guimier
organisation typiquement allemande appel
du syndicat du livre un arrêt de travail
de quinze minutes
mesure symbolique pour marquer le coup
mais sans désorganiser la vie économique
collecte d'argent pétition chaque comité
local s'était fixé un objectif très
concret l'argent récolté servira à
améliorer l'aménagement d'un foyer
d'asile nous voulons que les étrangers
qui vit et tout le confort nécessaire
symbolique aussi mais avec beaucoup plus
d'ampleur
des dizaines de manifestations dans les
grandes et les moins grandes villes
d'allemagne berlin ce soir chen
lumineuse pour dire non à la violence et
au racisme lieu éminemment symbolique la
porte de brandebourg
si même le 30 janvier 1933 défilé à la
lueur des flambeaux les nazis fêtaient
leur victoire
hitler venait d'être nommé chancelier en
toute légalité
l'allemagne ne savait pas encore qu'elle
connaîtrait 12 ans de dictature et le
monde une guerre totale qui ferait plus
de 40 millions de victimes
soixante ans plus tard jour pour jour
des milliers et des milliers de petites
lumières l'allemagne tolérante commémore
mais ne célèbre pas l'allemagne
d'aujourd'hui se rappelle un moment
douloureux un moment honteux de son
histoire la chaîne lumineuse de berlin à
former ces simples mots ni videurs plus
jamais ça
le pays donne l'impression de s'être
ressaisi depuis trois mois environ 3
millions d'allemands sont ainsi
descendus dans la rue pour prouver que
l'extrême droite ici dès qu'une toute
petite minorité
et puis surtout si les violences
racistes se font moins nombreuses c'est
tout simplement que la police et la
justice allemande se sont enfin mis à
faire leur travail sérieusement car en
1993 comme il ya 60 ans l'extrême droite
ne pourra faire l'étalagé de sa force et
de sa violence comme si et seulement si
la démocratie
fiche de la faiblesse